so I'm going to be this lecture
correspond
of anti fragile so I've written a book
that has different sections the
principle one at the end is about ethics
and there's one on optionality we're
going to be talking about as innovation
as optionality I have to explain one
option is what innovation is all that
then I get 45 minutes and then we can
take questions but please during the Q&A
out of respect for the other person
don't make a lecture because it takes
out time it takes time away from the
other person wants to ask another
question so the next 45 minutes I'm
going to be reading from page 423 to
page 485 is it'll kill you so of the
book and and and and then you know you
can ask questions okay so page 4 clintus
okay I'll do something about that the
year so let me tell you how it all
started okay my sort of will be a little
biographical because can two separate
I can't separate okay it's not can you
raise the mike rinder is the volume or
is there someone there or Oh a drop
water on my computer so can someone have
a oh it has
we made this disrupt collection all
right this is okay we're going to be
discussing fragility all right I'm going
to be discussing fragility
I think my all right oh thanks so thanks
for it's still working but I think it's
working on its own thanks to the water
but I think Apple is what about a few
miles down the road okay okay so let me
give you my sort of biographical story
and my obsession with what I call fat
tails to explain fat tails what you have
here is the performance of an option
portfolio the variation in price of an
option portfolio daily variation over 57
years okay so out of the money options
options that are remote is about 10 to
12 thousand days something like that 14
thousand days and as you can see there's
a big spike for that portfolio that day
represents depends on what you've been
doing between 80 and 99 percent of your
total lifetime variation if you're an
option trader one day in your life
should represent 98 percent of the
variation if you are involve in remote
payoffs this in other words is what I
call fat tails and this is of course if
you don't get that day right you're not
going to get anything right and and and
it's not predictable okay they tell you
it's predictable if you go to the
finance building they think is
predictable if you got economics
building that convinced is predictable
it is not predictable so that's the
problem is that they are events that
have a huge impact and we can't tell at
a time when they're going to come and we
have no idea about their structure and
put people fool themselves thinking they
have no idea about a structure so you
have to understand what domains are
affected by these large deviations and
also I don't know if your
one hears from Brooklyn but in Brooklyn
they say that you should make lemonade
every time someone gives you a lemon so
you got to make lemonade out of it so
this is the idea that we have there's a
huge amount of these events the rare
event representing a large share of the
pie now you live here at the epicenter
of rare events okay
Google represent this spike in its own
business
all right Microsoft on Microsoft was
Microsoft it's still Microsoft but you
know what is even more Microsoft than
this today there was 50,000 computer
companies and it had more than half the
sales in that segment ok if you take the
stock market over the past hundred years
a lot of company joined a lot of company
left there are about 12,000 surviving
companies that are listed are these
12,000 companies how many companies
represent half the capitalization what
do you think sorry well when I was
trading some some years was 50 to 100
some years was 300 to 400 there's no
structure ok another example for example
is a book business I don't know if you
know about the book business there are
million manuscripts in the English
language on the market today by people
who call themselves writers but
typically they were in the u.s. they
work for Starbucks and in Europe they
they do other things they work for the
government so they call themselves
writers their novels are the million
novels literary novels about 20,000 will
be published of these half the sales
will come from how many books sorry
20% no between 5 and 15 some years less
than 5 it's not 20% it's very really we
are in what I call extreme stat so let
me give you an idea of what is
extremists an
if I can figure out how to work this
computer if you imagine that you have
convention here and you bring in a
random selection of people from the
planet a thousand people bring them to
Stanford nice weather you know great way
to convince people to come and put it on
scale all right you weigh them you add
to that sample the heaviest person you
can find on the planet who can still be
called a person how much of the total
with that person represent sorry okay so
say three times the average as we say in
finance 30 basis points alright point
three percent and if you move from a
thousand to ten thousand how many how
much will that person represent nothing
three basis points okay so the maximum
you can get will affect your average
very little this is commonly known as
the law of what large numbers about
everything you do the statistical basis
based on that law that as your sample
becomes larger no deviation is going to
mess up things for you agree if you eat
you know I eat I don't know I consume
eight hundred thousand calories a year
not a single day is going to make me you
know double my my phone my my weight all
right thank God but unfortunately not a
single day would make me lose half my
weight unless you know I have surgery
alright so the problem is that but then
finance can you lose half your fortune
in one day of course when I became a
potrait ER there's a walk then there's
something called new-member
a badge means rookie so you get abuse by
old traders were bored want to give
someone life advice for life so they
grab you so one guy grab hick come over
here kiddo he said okay I showed up he
said that was before this event
incidentally he said listen you see the
guy over there said yes he said his name
is Edie yes he said at a time was a lot
of money he made seven million in seven
years said yes he lost them all in seven
seconds
okay said good dough now you can go all
right that was his advice that you can
you know that you're an extremist an the
reasoning is different so everything is
moved by extremes in economic life and
visibly you're here for that to
understand that point and we're going to
take it to its conclusion so the first
visibly it leads to unpredictability if
I know how to I think that the water has
done the damage I think the water has
done it because I lost control over the
mouse see the mouse doesn't want to move
this is what happens when you take risks
in life sorry I'm going do this sorry
it's someone here an expert on yes to
the rescue opposite presenters you hold
on harm is out of you okay so this leads
to what I call a predictability there
kill you open intelligence we can do
this
no no the point is that okay this leads
to unpredictability and now we have
worst approved ability let me remove
this okay and use my thing in extremist
an okay things are unpredictable in
video Christine you can predict things
all right so that's point number one
unpredictability is a problem in of
course in a real world
unlike the textbooks I've seen you guess
you've seen this before
you recognize this item this is commonly
known as what
a wheel very good what was it discovered
sorry long time ago how long ago but at
least 6000 years ago
alright Babylonian technology right so
this is technology so let's see moving
from this technology to this technology
you guys are too young to remember the
days when it had to slip to carry our
luggage because in have wheel how long
did it take 6,000 years to miss
discovery right ok so you realize that
there is unpredictability not only that
but now we're going to look at something
else that they are domains that are
entirely dominated by the unpredictable
medical discovery for example entirely
dominated by the rare event they don't
know it and we're going to talk now
about luck with a caveat it's not really
luck it's a function of luck how to
exploit luck by which you get more
upside than downside of luck so and the
idea is you know what this is windmill
the two approaches in life the first one
that you hear that they're going to be
wins would and you know the conservative
attitude is to build what a wall to
protect oneself from the wind a better
attitude is to build wind bales if you
hear their well ok so the idea is to
milk uncertainty and try to exploit
disorder but before getting there we're
going to have little excursion into what
I call fragility there's something
interesting that I discovered that took
me about 21 years to figure out 21 years
I was an option traded for 21 years and
then realized something I knew
unconsciously but only became conscious
of it one day as I was looking at this
patently ugly teacup all right we have a
definition of fragility very simply
connected to what we saw about options
and let me let me propose the following
its fragile what doesn't like volatility
if this teacup is on a table and there's
an earthquake will it benefit from it no
you say very simple it is it wants
fragile because it wants calm and
predictability its harmed by disorder
you guys have earthquakes in California
it doesn't want an earthquake it doesn't
want to be in California I'd rather be
in New York you see very simply and now
from this concept of fragility we're
going to get into innovation and
optionality so this the way I see it is
short optionality and let's look at what
short optionality is I think my computer
is improving but I think it's within the
system that there is a problem okay I'm
talking to you guys I'm worried about my
computer because I did something on
Mathematica for coming so understand two
hours of work you're operating this is a
payoff of a financial structure that is
very vulnerable to phone calls at night
when villainized the chairman of the
company gets a phone calls in oh there's
an event
so this payoff this package you know you
make or lose some money but typically
the losses right are very large and the
profits are very small exactly like the
coffee cup except the coffee cup has no
variation except for the loss the coffee
cup will never improve let's see if you
can connect this this package is robust
and this package has an opposite payoff
where all the gains are large the kind
of thing that only people in California
seem to understand people in New York
they don't get it because people in New
York have this payoff and let me explain
the banks are in a business of hiding
risks so they make make make make make
make small they have no volatility you
know most of the time and once every 10
or so years guess what they lose
everything they made and then they come
to the taxpayer for support they they
have the set up for people to you know
give them monetary policy to help them
and all that stuff and meanwhile they
keep their bonuses because it's a very
efficient strategy where you make you
make make everybody think you're smart
and then when you lose guess what it was
it was a bad environment okay it was
only a quarter when you lost but visibly
you've lost more than you ever made
banks lost in 2008 modern history
banking alright and and of course they
paid themselves a lot of money they
didn't return it to us so this is a
payoff that's very similar to a short an
option you sell an option you have very
little return you earn some money but
then something happens you have
unlimited losses or very large losses
that pay off resemble the fragile the
opposite of that payoff would be
something that's long volatility so when
I went you know to try to explain this
people were understanding that the
opposite of fragile isn't robust it's
not solid it is not the opposite of
fragile the opposite of this is not the
straight line it's not a payoff you know
where you know you end up unharmed
you agree if I'm sending a package to
say Mongolia interior right and the
package is fragile
what do I write on it fragile alright
okay if the package is a robust but you
write on it nothing so if the package
once volatility wants to be harmed wants
something one stressors wants disorder
once earthquakes all right it's not the
same as robust it would be something on
which you'd write please
handle I am anti fragile it's the
opposite of fragile so the opposite of
fragile is not something that is robust
or something solid it's something that
was disorder and guess what there is
something called the cluster and if you
like one you like them all
uncertainty variability and perfect
incomplete knowledge transkei loss these
if you benefit from all of these you are
classified as anti fragile and it's very
similar to someone who owns an option so
we're going to talk about you know how
you guys can milk randomness because
that's what you do in California right
and we're going to be a little more
technical and a little more rigorous in
a way we analyze an option payoff so
that was my idea of what an option is
and why people don't quite understand
what it means
this computer definitely doesn't like me
today
maybe the proximity of Apple caused me
to make these you know just to have this
problem okay so there are things now
let's do the world in three categories
there's a fragile like this computer you
pour water on it it's gone right you
understand and now we have to give a
lecture maneuvering with a mouse and
maneuvering so it doesn't blow up and
hope it can doesn't blow up before the
end of this lecture right that's a
fragile okay that's the definition
there's a robust you hammer it nothing
happens but doesn't benefit from it and
there's the anti fragile that likes
disorder and benefits from the solar and
benefits from error so happened that now
we can identify the fragile there's a
method to figure out what is fragile and
there's a method to figure out what is
anti fragile how very simple something
related to convexity let me explain what
I mean by numb by convexity or concavity
okay if I jump I am fragile my body is
fragile okay if I jump 10 meters what
would happen to me
you guys are engineers and smart people
who you would know what happened what
would happen to me sorry screech I die
I'm gonna say it this is you know you
die in hospital you hospital here won't
be any good right you die when you fall
ten meters but if I fall ten times 1
meter what would happen to me nothing it
means that every additional meter harms
me more than the previous one
no aha everything fragile we saw it in
time series space but if you look at it
as a response
everything fragile has to have
accelerating harm at some point and we
can actually show that everything that
has an accelerating horn doesn't like
volatility and the opposite of it is
something that has accelerating benefits
you see let's you know look at it those
response and the best example and
everything and this is universal this is
what I find is 495 maneuvers computer
come on please please sorry the what the
blazes it's working you know we're
maneuvering with this all right so the
the nonlinear is on more you see this
accelerating harm is harm a lot more
than the linear and visibly the linear
for small variation so more response
than the nonlinear this is very this is
easier to understand if you look at it
this way you saw that my the horn I get
from hitting the floor okay it has to be
nonlinear for me to be harmed at 10
meters but not to be harmed at 10 times
1 meter you agree ok it has to be that
way because walking you know from on
campus would kill you otherwise
because being harmed by that large but
you get the if it is if the thing were
linear you'd be killed so harm for
anything that has not been broken has to
be in a non linear the coffee cup sees
thousands of hits very small intensity
like very small pounds per inch it's it
doesn't really care but one big hit and
it breaks
so things that are fragile have to be
nonlinear and this is what central
abouts idea you have to be accelerating
and harm another example is look at the
world around us okay if we were linear -
horn will blown up long time ago the
world has three to four million
earthquakes every year lower low
intensity on a guy geiger scale you say
it would be like a Fukushima every few
minutes if it were it's the HAR more
linear but it's not see yeah yeah so
this is quite central because now we can
figure out where the fragile from
nonlinear and look at its opposite
simply we have the following if you have
more gain say if the market goes up 10%
you make more money than the market went
down 10% then you lose it the market
went down 10% your convex you see and
otherwise you're concave the best way to
figure it out is with this this is
convex
this is concave if you want to remember
this is convex and this is concave okay
so if you look at the payoff of the
convex you make more then you lose
you're here you make more than you lose
here for an equivalent one or you make
more the second time than you make the
first time the market goes up 20% you
make more than twice its market one up
10% if you are in that situation then
you like volatility if you're in that
situation then you are like benefiting
from randomness that what I call the
disorder brothers uncertainty all these
things let me take one or two questions
here before continuing and as you're
asking the question I can look at and
see if I can fix the computer yes the
upside of the convex curve but it seems
to me that on the other side of your
smiley face you would lose no ya
increasing has to be increasing but
you're not going to be here also I mean
it's not going to be harm here this is F
f of X and this is X and if you're here
you say or decreasing but not very at a
decreasing rate you say for the
increasing all right
you make more than you lose and for the
decreasing it slows down any other
question the idea is for you to see the
connection between convex the idea
attitude connection and lights
volatility think about why the convex
likes volatility
you can do it here instead of getting X
all the time you're getting X plus 50%
sometimes or X minus 50% sometimes that
linear combination is much better than
just getting X so we like volatile you
like variability that's why you know the
answer fragile but all this is linked
the same graph can explain to us now why
being in your business is great has this
been moving on its own or no when I was
here I'm sitting here you see I told you
this technology is not very reliable so
I did the very similar okay I did a
simple very simple experiment on my
computer I generated two kind of series
one where a person knows where he's
going very intelligent person who knows
where he's going but doesn't have any
convexity in his payoff the other one
the person who doesn't know where he's
going
has no idea but has convexity in his
payoff you say look at the difference
between the two trial and error is an
option why look at trial and error as
something like this
you loose loose loose loose loose loose
loose and once in a while you make a lot
you say exactly like the opposite of the
coffee cup like what we saw before
something that gains from disorder and
gain from black swans
that's trial and error okay you're in
the business of trial and error someone
who tried does trial and error versus
someone with directed ideas is going to
perform extremely well when you have
randomness and what we're going to see
is why when you have trial and error you
outperform someone who knows
because convexity matters a lot more
than knowledge you don't know what's
going on you keep trying to have an
irrational or laughs rational enough not
to make mistakes by doing the same trial
twice or having a result and giving it
up so we can generate rules from this
and I was thinking of seven rules
because people like the number seven
look here seven money rules for life
there's here seven rules for success all
right seven rules for weight loss all
right you can do that as well and seven
rules for change management okay so I
also say okay I'm going to come up with
my seven rule but then I realize you
guys will not remember the seven rules
as you leave this place
so you have to understand how an option
works and once you understand how an
option works then you understand one
word how to milk to have to be in a
position where you are anti fragile and
benefit from randomness it's a big big
big misnomer that trial and error you
know or lock benefiting from luck all
right is a good and is the word trial
and error is a misnomer we should not
say trial and error you should say
convex function of randomness or trial
with small error
okay trial and add the error has to be
small so the anti-federal your
environment where the errors are small
and of small cost and the gains are
large and unlimited
and then you are positioned properly
those that lacks one unpredictability
all these things this is what central
and you can model it exactly like an
option and an option increases
monstrously in value when there is
volatility
now there's some good news and bad news
is that people don't quite understand
that optionality concept in this book
for I'm attacking the notion that we got
to where we are because of the superb
and collect and brilliance of the
ancients that's not the case
we got the way we are thanks to people
who are taking risks involved in trial
and error the problem is I call it
lecturing birds have to fly people birds
you know if you lecture Birds tell them
this is how you should be flying and
birds will fly according to your
principles then you can claim credit you
agree and then everybody would believe
that because you never say it's called
epi phenomenal because you never see the
birds flying without someone lecturing
it okay now it's the same thing with the
problem we have is education right
people have this impressive this idea
that science race technology so if you
take a book any book you have this idea
science technology all right practice it
looks like it's exactly backwards in
history but the problem is that birds
don't write books last time I checked
who writes books those will lecture
birds so we have a next generation of
people who will forget you know how it
was before now let's take the history of
technology to me it comes from
optionality discoveries and then someone
formalizes it and dresses it up as you
know this is directed research this is
from a top-down and in fact all comes
from trial and error you don't know
where you're going you don't know where
you're going but the harm is small so
it's much closer to
King you see how do you cook trial and
error you agree you can't you don't take
a chemistry class even except if it's a
with T now you know because she wrote a
book on chemistry of cooking but but you
don't really take a chemistry class then
work out the equations they're chemical
and then get your perfect dish know how
does it work you try you taste the harm
is small if you're wrong and by little
by little and after three or four
generation of trial collective trial and
error you get a good dish like
choucroute or you get whatever or
sourdough bread or kind of thing you
have here you see this is cooking well
it looks like technology resembles
cooking but we read the wrong books and
then matter of investigating how things
were derived you see whether it's
optionality or whether it was knowledge
in book for a start book for with this
story by Aristotle he was talking about
Alice of mellitus okay and Dallas made a
killing he was a philosopher and he was
tired of the people who were telling
them listen philosopher you know you're
a philosopher you're schmuck you get the
idea you can't make money plus the guy
was Phoenicians so you can't make any
money who is tired of these people he
wanted to prove that he was
philosophizing because he loved that
business not because he was incompetent
all right
now moving on it by itself or as moving
left if you've noticed going backwards
to the seven rules okay so what did he
do he went in and put some his money
some bets on olive presses weight-loss
business it's okay so he put some money
on all the presses he went in and make
made a bet that was going to be a demand
for olive presses he put a little money
on it and of course there was a lot of
demands the season was great and he made
tons of he made a fortune okay now what
does Aristotle write that Alice made a
fortune because he read the stars and
predicted okay a great season for olives
all right high demand for all
presses but in fact what the Tallis have
he had an option
he had a down payment a call like the
right to use the olive press by putting
very little money on it they say
had he been wronged it would have cost
him nothing so we just ride ten thousand
times over about ten thousand times
maybe ten twenty thirty whatever high
number of times at no big harm you see
he would have been breaking even you
know breaking even breaking even
breaking even and making a killing once
in a while and that's where really what
he had is a big payoff
that was to what Alice said was a big
payoff not really it didn't come from
this is moving on his own
all right so so the so let me try this
shutdown and restart do this okay so so
the the problem with with with Dallas is
that was a story is that we have this
impression oh and I'm only two miles
from Apple okay
the problem with a story of Dallas is
that they were convinced people were
convinced that all this great thing came
from knowledge when in fact goes from
trial and error and then if we continue
I what I did here and I can find it here
probably in the book which also his wife
but you see much less fragile because
you can still wet book doesn't play
tricks on you you can figure out that in
a history all right a lot of things that
were discovered by trial and error that
later masqueraded as coming from
top-down research and then nobody gets
credit for trial and error we've known
for example lot of things think of
Euclidean geometry you think that we
need geometry to put buildings now
that's what people think no all right
we had York Lydian geometry since the
second century okay all right the people
use it to build you know these big did
the Romans use it
no nobody used it they had their own
heuristics their own tricks come in from
trial and
and they only used it later okay after
the 15th century by the 15th century
there were only four people capable of
do making a long hand division in Europe
so I take that example another example
is another example patent example other
than sorry
which one pyramids avoid the pyramids I
were built before you take a lot of
things I'm sorry Peninsula what
penicillin was disgusting in medicine is
discovered like viagra but by by error a
side-effect of something else and then
people you know like viagra as the
nurses were were complaining from
behavior on its floor with it on the
trial so you get the idea for a and it
was a blood pressure medicine so the
there are a lot of examples of stories
backward even cybernetics you think is
Wiener normal Wiener in fact just
someone sent me a book as I was writing
this about the the that it was practiced
by technicians way before and of course
no credit for them you say so the this
computer is this is the first time I
encounter well now it's working
look it's not working okay
the so let me take some questions here
as a computer as I find my bearings let
me take you a question on this yes
isn't there in general and mix that is
true so there's something called yes the
bacterium in the stomach that causes
ulcers it has always believed that there
was no bacterial estimate when
discovered could encode by chance by two
guys went on vacation left things
no not came back but it was not by
chance that the end of the step okay
soon as a mix of it there is a mix
coming for optional case when you mix
the two but effectively there is some
kind of improvement in scientific
knowledge built from optionality you see
improvement that helps you conduct other
experiments but typically the role of
knowledge is highly overstated so we
have this impression that things were
driven a lot more by design than they
were by luck you see but the point is
it's not luck it is a convex function of
luck it is by thinking it's a convex
function of luck this is what is quite
important in this is that you had more
upside than downside to whatever you're
doing the biggest improvements we had in
meta didn't discuss drug discovery what
was what people had no idea what they're
doing but knew that the kept trying dies
okay till they found something
and today we're directing and we haven't
been able to find much now we know that
you know we know so many things we
understand bacteria virus that we
haven't been able to find as much as we
did in a period when it's purely trial
and error so we continue with this idea
of trial and error has optionality leads
us remember the seven rules okay - maybe
you can make 77 rules you can make lot
of rules but the principle should always
be to be on the right side of convexity
because convexity will pay you a lot
more in the long run than direction so
what do you do it the first thing is
make sure that you have optionality
you're not locked into a business plan
like you're not locked on
a highway with no exit yes people know
that if your convex you're you benefit
from extra bone yes but you've now
polarized this idea right this is no I
mean and maybe people knew about it
before so who are you going to buy these
options from could be for every person
that says this is very interesting now
when we talk about anti fragile is gains
from randomness and volatility the in
financial option you buy the option from
someone you agree but in real life is or
buy it from anyone trial and error
you're not buying it from anyone this is
not a financial option this is a real
option that's number one - you still
have an option that you're buying very
cheap whenever you buy if you buy a
house and you have a mortgage you
already have an option you see people
don't understand you have the option and
for a long time for a long time you know
people were getting even greater options
from banks so the built in the explicit
option is not what I'm talking about
here what I'm talking about is embedded
option in things or option like
characteristics inch things and if you
take the formation of wealth in history
it all came from this optionality other
questions yes like in an industry right
for the airline industry where the
errors are costing with toss you know
okay - but there is explicit trial and
error where you are willing to take the
error okay there's explicit trial and
error this is a system that has explicit
trial and error where you you know you
think are voluntarily and you have to
maintain your error small and make sure
it's not like a lottery ticket where the
upside is known someone's overcharging
you for it as a financial option and
it's open-ended you see the the but but
also their businesses okay where you
make mistakes in which case you want to
make the mistakes as small for the
system as possible and never let a
mistake go to waste by exploiting them
so let me give you an example you know
you just mentioned the transportation
industry okay every plane crash which is
an error leads to the improvement of the
safety of traveling
we haven't had a plane crash in America
commercial the commercial plane crash in
one or three years and before that it
was more than three years so or a lethal
one so you realize that there are
businesses that even if they can have a
large error to make sure it's one at a
time
not like monetary policy where you have
big mistakes or you know politics where
we have one person make a big mistake
that cost so much in lives and money
like a war you see you want your
mistakes to be small when you can't
avoid having mistakes you want them to
be to remain small and typically top
down things make large mistakes this is
what my idea of decentralization of you
have to decentralize the errors by
making sure they remain small and
distributed okay but when you're
willingly making errors because they're
small and because there's a lot of huge
cost when you're willingly then you want
you say then you want to make error you
want to make a lot of errors because
they're not as harmful you say and the
payoff come from it but remember one
thing you saw my first graph where I was
showing you the returns in this business
okay the the strategy that immediately
comes to mind from that is that you
can't be directed if a lot of your
returns are going to come from one what
are you going to do what you need to do
you had to be as broad as you can in
your strategy that's number one but you
can't do it if you're an entrepreneur an
entrepreneur bye-bye-bye-bye design is
not broad and if you're going to have
trials you could probably you can't have
the 20 trials in a lifetime but
collectively Society has been benefiting
from this army of entrepreneurs very few
of them managed to buy the big houses
around here here real estate she's
telling me it's hugely expensive you see
very few win and then the remaining
people are like soldiers who fall in
battle for the sake of the system which
is why I was calling for a national
entrepreneur day and and then suddenly
it happened by the way all right
but didn't get credit for it it happened
on publication on the pub day of the
book by the way so the the
entrepreneur day because hey you know
what we salute fallen soldiers as some
because they're needed for the system
for the collective that needed for the
system to further to prove the system we
need soldiers to fall we should do the
same for entrepreneurs because realize
how few win and you don't want the other
ones to be demoralized you want to thank
them for getting involved in their side
of trial-and-error without having
anything but errors all their lives but
they're doing it for the sake of the
system and this is what it is see
there's something moral about what
you're doing if you try and you know to
improve the system
something moral even if you fail
especially if you fail you say and this
is what people don't understand we bail
out we tend to bail out corporations
that are rotten and fragile okay we
don't bail out entrepreneurs which would
be bailing out entrepreneurs which
should also make it more honorable the
only place I'm honored to be here the
only place on a planet where it's
honorable to fail is here before that it
was used to be
guess where couple centuries ago where
no no an entrepreneurship an
entrepreneurship sorry
England England that pulled out at
Industrial Revolution
thanks to these aggressive thinkers you
see so you have that was that was when
and now with the problem is look at
England what happened to England the
minute you get rich from tinkering you
had the illusion of being able to
replicate it through Whitehall an
economic policy and Whitehall research
policy and this minister of policy and
stuff like that they didn't have that
when they pulled up you see and the
minute they had that of course they went
to the relative decline compared to
other places so so you see you have to
let the things develop organically on
their own and thinkers are mad because
that's how systems operate let me take
more questions yes I'll conclude with
the question Pierre go ahead Terry Paul
students ago and
ten minutes where they're talking about
ending quantitative diesel and then
quantities could leak inadvertently uses
I'm sorry he's asking me he's telling me
that something not related to the stock
but he knew that I'm very interested in
topic which is federal policy today
leaked that they're ending quantitative
easing no I'm not involved in journalism
or or commenting I'll put it on on
events but I'm going to talk about
monetary policy okay if you later
we should exact the thing is what the
Fed has has been doing the idea of the
government they don't understand
antifragility they don't understand that
when you have a crisis it should come
out of it better than you were before
you guys had your crisis in California
and remember 2000 you weren't born many
of ok so almost all right so you came
out of it better off than before know it
cleaned up the system so you should
never let the crisis to waste now what
happened in Japan and here and in Europe
they have a crisis now they shoot to
establish the system to bring it back to
what it was before
without letting what is fragile break
and new things come in its place you say
so the monetary policy aims at
preserving the satu quo and then also a
side effect is of course to enrich those
who who were involved in the crisis
right in causing the crisis and of
course it's not good to have such a you
know to have very easy money because you
don't want people to take money and go
gamble with it in the stock market you
want it to go use the money for what
you're doing the real thing is a
trial-and-error that that they don't get
respect for for losing a little bit all
the time
other questions yes relevant bankruptcy
which essentially grants the original
proprietor is the ability to keep on
doing what they do what do I think about
chapter 11 I have a written two things
about the notion of limited liability
okay
the the if it's used okay for this trial
and error then it's very good if limited
liability if limited liability is use
to transfer your losses to society so
you get the bonus the upside and society
gets the downside then it's not good you
say and what has happened in the
catalystic system is instead of having
incentives and disincentives we have
some people who have the incentives and
then when they lose money take banks
they make bonuses when they have good
years and then when they have a bad year
they transfer it to society so the
taxpayer and they keep their bonuses as
we saw before again remember the two
kind of pay off the pay off where you
lose a lot to make small and the other
pay off which is what you have here when
you lose small to make big you say now
those who lose a you know a little bit
who you know lose a little bit to make
big are not gaming the system because
the taxpayer doesn't bail you out have
you heard of a bailout of any company in
California no because you guys all your
big volatility of the in the upside not
the downside you see but the other ones
has a big volatility to the downside and
they lose more than their capital and
someone has to pay for the losses it
ends up needing a tax payer other
questions yes everything yes so you have
all these things to say about the nature
of building being able to predict things
but we also use probabilistic AI a lot
and we are using it more and more in
every fuel okay he's saying he's saying
that I I'm sceptical about the use of
probability to predict and he told me
that in AI they predict a mediocre Stan
you can use probably very well it works
very well
outside mediocre Stan when you have
things dominated by rare event okay the
these things fall apart and they fall
apart I have I just put the text because
nobody was understanding my Black Swan
they would read it and comment and write
articles I'm not even wrong about it my
point is that large deviations occur
they are unpredictable okay no matter
how many
phd's you put on it they're
unpredictable and all the people who
relied are predicting rare events have
blown up and this is how actually you
can make money on Wall Street you
identify those will rely on
probabilities to compute the risk of
rare events and make sure they're going
to go bust like Fannie Mae or like
others and you can make a buck and
celebrate you know being right with
these guys so I'm saying but if we're a
I you can apply it for small problems
that don't have big tail effects yes you
can definitely apply it we use
probabilities for anything for for
insurance for on your house for
insurance medical insurance is probably
works beautifully these domains and then
casino is it perfect okay yes yeah
brother us after the billion dollars and
25 years you got any idea yes when you
have a okay how did we get to where we
are today you lose small to make big so
because you have to have a lot of trial
to get to the destination okay if you
are what I call teleological and a slide
that I can show and think you know where
you're going then you can bypass a trial
and error because you have great
scientists and great scientific
understanding and it looks like Pharma
got to where it is today through
accidents the side effect of drugs side
effect the thing and now suddenly they
woke up and said okay now we're going to
target results you say when in fact it's
a collective effect of a lot of firms
trying and those who succeed thought
that they succeeded because their brains
not that they succeeded because of their
taken advantage of luck you see that's
the problem of pharma today and pharma
has more problems than that in the past
you come up with a drug okay you had to
look at side-effects and probably a few
other drugs today we have 850,000
authorized drugs okay something like
that and one hundred and some thousand
existing drugs alright
so every time you introduce a drug you
got to look at side-effect
our patient and you got to look at Co
you see Co side-effects and then you
have to look at try side-effect with
sweet and all these drug interactions
that you had becoming more and more
unpredictable so Pharma is in trouble in
that sense plus there's another thing in
my book here that I discuss about the
subsystems that sometimes curing people
it's much easier to do by subtraction
you see subtraction is much easier cz7
rules all these rules are positive means
do this to this to this as much the
Charlatans typically have nothing but
positive rules people who are you know
scientist or philosophical have negative
rules okay don't do this don't do that
it's much more rigorous actually and
they don't have side effects so if
instead of curing people by giving them
drug every time we looked at subtractive
methods remove things like for example
remove cigarettes from society you save
more it's more effective than anything
we're spending on drugs and cumulatively
more than anything done since penicillin
they say I don't believe the statistic
when I saw it and in fact it or not to
be true if you just remove cigarettes if
you remove corn sugar okay remove by
removal if you remove diabetes the first
thing people do is give people drugs nor
if you send them to Siberia or didn't
have the money
put them on 500 calories a day for 3
months come out of it fluent and Russian
or reversal in Russian and it's more
effective than any drug initially
alright but what the protocols you start
instead of starving people because it's
a stressor that someone needs
we aren't anti facial to variation if we
derived of if we are deprived of these
variations we get weaker so if you if
you some people the first thing they do
is try to give you a drug instead of
removing right instead of removing food
try to give you something and
effectively now epileptic see if you
have you know a child has at you know
that exceeds the first thing they do is
give them drugs whereas the most
effective treatment is removal of all
sugars you say and we know if no now
for 70 years but Pharma doesn't make any
money removing things from your system
nobody's going to make any money if you
stop smoking directly if you stop
smoking they're not going to sell you
something unless they sell you method to
stop smoking you see so this is what was
the problem there's a gentleman in the
back it's hard to disentangle luck and
ability such as trading how do you
device an effective compensation or
payment scheme I believe in something I
call skin in the game okay
skin in the game is a defined skin in
the game it's most moral and effective
to remove risks is that nobody should
ever put someone else at risk I don't
really care about compensation okay I
don't really care about ranking because
you can't have a trading competition
because someone has a strategy that pays
off very rarely okay he will lose in the
competition he lose every battle and win
the war you see so I can't really rank
traders but there's one rule I have a
cold skin in the game that nobody should
put others at risk without having harm
to himself okay in other words if you
lose money to your clients
you should be exposed to the same risk
that's sort of it most moral and risk
management rule risk management because
I'm Hammurabi's code
it was simple as an architect build the
house and the house is fragile but
hidden fragilities in a basement you get
the idea
we're in the foundation like in a bank
system banking systems they look very
stable but they have they cut corners
that nobody will see okay to make the
bonus and if the house collapses the
architect is penalized that was in
Hammurabi's code actually is put to
death if the house collapses and kill
the owner of the house so this system
okay is the best this is the best risk
management rule because as Hammurabi
discovered but some things I forget
today in Washington the architect or
engineer knows a lot more about the
risks he doesn't know a lot about the
risk but he definitely knows a lot more
than the inspector you say so if you
make people eat their own
King you see their lot better off okay
and someone sent me read my book and
sent me something a story in Brazil
where they discovered that they could
lower the rate of helicopter crashes by
forcing helicopter engineers randomly to
take a ride have now arrived once a
months and helicopter all right now
sorry for example something the Romans
knew and Victorian knew that you make
engineer sleep under the bridge right
okay so in trading what do you do so
long as whoever is whoever is involved
in strategy has losses small okay it
doesn't matter right has losses if it
can harm others in other words it has
some incentive but some disincentive
then we should be okay it's when people
don't have disincentive when they lose
that the system blows up yes systems are
moving to areas and stays qualitex
today's top-down so does your theory of
antifragility have some implications or
some suggestions on how politics should
go forward to reduce experience the idea
that I proposed is very simple along the
rules if you look at these rules very
simply that you want mistakes to be
small and gains to be large okay and a
mistakes side you want to distribute
mistakes then you necessarily need the
centralization you see the most stable
country in the world is Switzerland
where nobody knows who the president is
all right they can tell you that there
is Qaddafi's presence of this Asaf
residue don't know their own president
it's a system works well it's so
decentralized it's completely bottom-up
you see so mistakes are small so this
simple concept pervading the book
convexity means mistakes are small ok
concavity means mistakes are large and
rare you see at that simple system so we
don't have any more time I have another
lecture but thank you very much and
thanks Apple could someone worked for
Apple I would like to have word with
them now
thank you
I'm driver faces stvp dfj and the many
lovers of Finance are in this room and
washing virtually we'd like to thank you
thank you thank you very much
it's not edible oh okay great thanks
[Applause]
you